(energetic upbeat music)
- What's up, guys?
Michael here,
to talk about why learning
to control your emotions
is probably better than
using an army of Titans
to kill a lot of people.
Today, we're taking a philosophical look
at part two of season
four of "Attack on Titan".
Now, I already covered the
first part of season four
focusing on the philosophy
of antinatalism,
so be sure to check that out too.
But in this part of season
four plans have changed.
And we're now going from a
subtle, forced euthanasia plan
to a very unsettled
genocide by Titans plan.
So are there any philosophical
revelations to be gleaned,
from all of this unhinged,
rage and violence?
Well, for my Wisecrack colleague, Lux,
the key might be looking at it
through the perspective of stoicism.
Stoicism is a philosophical tradition
that holds that if you
wanna live a virtuous life,
you should follow logical principles
rather than unbridled
emotions and feelings.
Sort of like how you always feel
like you can eat five
to six slices of pizza
when logically it's
more like two or three,
with a side of salad, that
is if you're a quitter.
So cover your naps and
step away from the walls,
because in this addition
of a philosopher reacts
we're gonna dig deep into
attack on Titan season four,
part two to ask, can stoicism save us?
And spoilers ahead!
(alarm blaring)
Okay guys, before we get into it,
and I promise this will
just take a second,
I wanted to quickly tell you
that we've recently updated
and upgraded our Patreon page
and I think you should check it out.
And there's a lot of
really fun stuff on there.
We're doing some extra podcast content
where you can hear from writers
and editors and researchers
at Wisecrack to hear about
the videos we're making.
If you like this video,
what you'll probably like is a new feature
where I am doing monthly
philosophy office hours,
where I'm gonna dive deeper
into a lot of the philosophical material
that comes up in our videos,
talk about the history of
philosophy, and most importantly,
answer questions from
you, all our patrons.
So if you haven't checked
it out in a while,
please do, there will be
a link in the description,
but now, let's get on with the show
and talk about "Attack On Titan".
Okay.
So part two of season four picks
up where part one left off,
meaning things are not going super well.
Eren and Zeke are on the verge
of carrying out their euthanasia plan
which we talked about in our last video
on "Attack On Titan",
but then after double crossing Zeke,
Erengets the power of the founding Titan
and goes all out to destroy
everyone on the planet
who isn't on Paradis Island.
While Eren is really going for it now.
Some of our friends and
enemies are working together
in a last ditch effort to stop
him from doing a genocide.
And then so much is Eren and the Yeagers,
and of course the Marleyans
are fueled by negative of emotions,
our gang of potential heroes has a chance
only if they stop relying on feelings,
and instead try to do something positive
by working towards some
genuinely good principles.
And how do they do this?
A little bit of good old fashion stoicism.
So what is stoicism?
Usually, if someone is described as stoic,
it's like when you're
talking about an old man
with no feelings who drinks
whiskey for breakfast
and is unexpectedly always chopping wood
and putting it into
neatly organized piles.
And while that dude obviously rips,
this is not quite
with the original stoic
we're talking about.
In a general sense, they were descendants
in the line of virtue ethics.
A school of thought that began with Plato
and really found its legs with Aristotle.
If you're unfamiliar with the concept,
Aristotle said that living a virtuous life
was all about orienting
your life towards happiness.
Now he used the term
Telos which means aim,
to describe the way in which a virtue
gives us an aim for our activity.
When he says happiness,
he's not referring to a
general feeling of contentment
or swimming in good
vibes and great oldies.
Instead, he's talking about eudaimonia,
which is a type of happiness
that has to do with human flourishing,
i.e. living your absolute best life.
The Stoics turned this idea of virtue
into a full on philosophy of life.
And it wasn't really
focused on heady concepts
or metaphysical ponds,
but about actual human existence.
Would've thought,
a philosophy that's just
about living your actual life.
Now for the Stoics,
the point of philosophy
was basically being good at life.
As Pierre Hadot describes it,
for the stoic then,
doing philosophy meant
practicing how to live.
That is, how to live
freely and consciously.
Consciously, in that we
pass beyond the limits
of individuality to recognize ourselves
as a part of the reason-animated Cosmos.
Freely, and that we give up desiring
that which does not depend on
us and is beyond our control
so as to attach ourselves
only to what depends on us,
actions which are just in
conformity with reason.
Okay.
Enough about long dead Greek dudes,
let's check out what happens
when emotions kind of
tear Zeke and Eren apart.
- [Zeke] (speaking in foreign language)
- [Eren] (speaking in foreign language)
- [Zeke] Eren...
- I didn't see this coming.
- [Eren] (speaking in foreign language)
- That Sucks.
You know, you find your long lost brother
and think you have someone
you can like love and trust.
Now, obviously this right
here is not stoicism.
But it's important to help
us understand stoicism
the same way that like
watching blood on the asphalt
in Driver's Ed helps you learn
about not speeding up the lover's lane
without your seatbelt on
and also why necking can
and will get you pregnant.
Now, what we just saw is basically
the opposite of stoicism.
And Zeke and Eren,
and of course like
everyone else on the show,
are being driven completely by passion,
namely anger and hatred,
and for the Stoics,
being virtuous wasn't simply
about orienting your life
around goodness.
It was also about control,
in particular, controlling
your passions and emotions.
So if a committed stoic
was driving on the freeway
after a horrible day at work
and got cut off by someone
with a baby on board sticker on their car,
they wouldn't be overcome with
the passion to flick them off
with a burning hatred.
Also, babies are bad drivers.
This because stoicism
necessitates controlling passions
and emotions so that when acts
solely unvirtuous principles.
And while giving someone the double birds
while using your knees
to drive the car is fun,
it's not virtuous.
What we see in both Zeke and Eren's plans
and their outcomes is what happens
when one's thoughts and
actions are dictated
by emotion and passion, and
not reason and deliberation.
So let's check out a
really interesting scene
where we flash back to
one of the many scenarios
that seem to be at the
heart of Eren's rage.
- [Eren] (speaking in foreign language)
(audience claps)
- Any political leader
that doesn't do that move,
they're never good.
Now here we get a flashback sequence
that gives us a little bit of insight
into Eren's initial decision
to sow the seeds of his genocide plan.
And it shows us what happens
when a motion takes over.
Now Eren and the Scouts
are visiting Marley
to try ice cream for the first time
and get blitz at a migrant
camp and forge a plan of peace
with the subjects of a
near protection group.
However, during this
meeting of the assembly,
the leader of the protection group
basically goes full Hitler
when he calls for the citizens of Paradis
to be exterminated.
This political fervor is very unstoic
and that it's both fueled
by emotion, namely hatred,
isn't oriented around any type of virtue,
things like courage,
justice, or moderation,
and is operating on the assumption
that one group of humans
is fundamentally inferior
to the other.
In contrast, Stoics would recognize
that nature has not given us that memo.
This right here is why logic
was crucial to the Stoics,
and I'm not talking about
the type of formal logic,
that's the philosophical
equivalent of algebra,
thank God, but a simple
logical deliberation
on whether or not a specific position
or set of actions is virtuous.
Again, following in the
Aristotelian tradition,
the Stoics consider logical deliberation
to be a crucial part of virtue.
That's because unbridled emotions
can easily sway one to extremes.
While logical consideration
helps us arrive at more moderate
and thus more virtuous positions.
And here we see the Scouts
come into the assembly,
hoping to arrive at a logical position.
But all they observe is genocidal fervor.
And it seems like this is a
sort of final straw for Eren
as his response to the Marleyans hatred
is just a much much, much gnarlier hatred
aimed back at them.
Now, another important aspect of stoicism
is that even when you're not
doing xenophobia for lulls,
living a good life isn't
just about seeking out things
that are pleasurable for you.
Things like wealth, health comfort,
and is this toilet paper or cake?
And in the wake of Eren's victory,
Jean is put in a position to
weigh his individual comfort
versus virtuous principles.
So let's check that out real quick.
- [Jean] (speaking in foreign language)
- I wanna come to your life.
- [Man] (speaking in foreign language)
- [Jean] (speaking in foreign language)
- Now here, Jean is tempted
by the opportunity to retire
and live a good life as a hero of Paradis.
Now, in one sense,
it might seem like
pursuing health and wealth
aren't bad things.
It might even be virtuous,
assuming that you're not
overtly hurting anyone
in the process.
But according to the Stoics,
something can only truly be
virtuous when it's also just,
meaning that the ends we pursue
don't make life (beep) for others
or happen at their expense.
Now, Jean could just hang out
and enjoy the spoils of war,
but in doing so, he's
basically going to be sleeping
in a bed built by genocide
which tend to have really scratchy sheets
that are soaked with tears
of anguish and despair.
Now, we see in the wake of Eren's plan,
that flock and the Yeagers got drunk
with power pretty quickly.
But those like Jean who are able to leave,
are operating more in line with stoicism,
as they're pursuing virtues,
like justice, courage and moderation
above pursuing power and wealth.
Okay.
Speaking of being virtuous,
what would the stoics think
about you feeding someone
to your mom to make her live?
I don't know.
Let's find out because someone does that.
- [Gabi] (speaking in foreign language)
- [Falco] (speaking in foreign language)
- [Connie] (speaking in foreign language)
- This is so, is very gnarly.
- [Man 1] (speaking in foreign language)
- [Armin] (speaking in foreign language)
- Actions do speak louder.
Now who among us wouldn't be
tempted to feed a human child
to our mother if it would
bring her back to life?
But even if we can kind of relate
to what Connie is doing
here, it's clear that again,
he's in this situation
because he's unable to deal with the pain
of losing his mother.
And this pain is led to a
plan that's not super logical
and is definitely not moral.
But you know just when
it seems like he's about
to drop human food into
his mom's tight mouth hole,
he's motivated to do something good
when he saves Armin from
doing suicide via Titan mom.
It seems to snap Connie out
of his plan to sacrifice Falco
and helps him realize the
virtue of doing what's right
even if it doesn't directly
benefit one's passions.
Okay.
In the next episode,
Hange has a similar moment
of seemingly stoic clarity.
Let's check that out.
- [Hange] (speaking in foreign language)
No, it's okay,
you're allowed to raise your voice
when you're saying that genocide is wrong.
That's a good life role.
You can always be loud.
Okay.
So here we see Hange coming
to a sort of crossroads
between passion and logic that
she realizes that genocide
of any sort is categorically wrong.
Plus, much of the ideology
perpetuated by Marley
is equally driven by emotions
like hatred and fear and
not by any logical reasons
and surely not for any virtuous reasons.
This is the point of the
season where we transition
from seeing a majority of our characters
unable to control their emotions
to one where they start
to sacrifice their own
individual interests
for the sake of a greater good.
Okay.
Let's skip ahead
just a little bit in the same episode.
- [] (speaking in foreign language)
- This is some real spit right now.
- [Hange] (speaking in foreign language)
Come on, join the team.
Join the team, Jean.
- [Hange] (speaking in foreign language)
Yeah. Okay.
So after Hange has her own
come to Stoic Jesus moment,
she's working convince
Jean to follow suit.
And after just being tempted by flock
with a cushy life in
the new Yeagers empire,
choosing virtue for Jean
means sacrificing a probably
pleasurable existence
for the sake of a difficult
and likely deadly journey
to do what is right.
And here, Jean, isn't just choosing to go
against his former Yeagers comrades.
He's also choosing to
work with a new group
to actively fight against Eren.
And in the process, he's
choosing principles over comfort.
Okay.
So there's this a scene that happens,
maybe someone will pop it in here
where after Jean decided to be a good guy,
he almost beats Reiner to death.
And it seems like maybe he's
not gonna go with our gang
but look what happens in the next morning.
- [Jean] (speaking in foreign language)
- So casual.
- [Man] (speaking in foreign language)
- If any of you ever
beat me almost to death,
the next morning, don't like bully me.
It's just a lot.
But we talked before about Jean presumably
being anti Eren's genocide, which is good,
and way more virtuous
than supporting genocide.
But it doesn't mean he's
gone full Stoic just yet,
that's what goes in the
scene right before this,
rage motivates him into trying
to beat Reiner to death.
So, you know, stoicism has
a bit of a learning curve
but at least he's on the right path.
But also don't beat
people up it's not good.
Okay. Before we wrap up, I
wanna look at one more clip.
This is from the pen ultimate
episode of the season.
Some things are not really
going well for our friends
who are trying to stop
Eren, but let's watch.
- [Annie] (speaking in foreign language)
- Things are rough, Annie.
- [Woman] (speaking in foreign language)
She said, she's gonna get off the ship.
It's like, where are you gonna go?
- [Woman] (speaking in foreign language)
- That's real,
saving the people whose
names he'll never know.
- [Annie] (speaking in foreign language)
- Oh, okay.
That's tense.
So earlier in the season, we
saw that up until this point,
Annie had largely been
motivated by a hatred
towards her adoptive father,
which evolved into a love for him
and a desire to rescue
him from the rumbling.
Now here, after realizing
her motivating aim
of saving her father
is no longer possible,
she seems like she kind
of wants to like give up.
But she recommits to the cause
because it's the right thing to do
even though it's very hard.
And there's an underlying melancholy here,
that's clear the odds
are very, very very much
against our gang right here.
But this right here brings
up another aspect of stoicism
which is the point of pursuing virtue
isn't to simply bring
about a desirable result.
The point is to act in
accordance with universal nature,
i.e. a sense of natural justice,
which will make you happy,
even if you don't actually get
the thing you were aiming at.
In this case, it seems clear that even
if our mini resistance
is destined to fail,
they will still experience
a type of happiness
in continuing to do what's right.
It's not dissimilar from
Immanuel Kant moral philosophy
in which right intention
matters as much, if not more,
than the right result.
As the season ends with
Eren's fInding Titan,
and his Titan army, stomping
out human civilization,
it at least seems like the best our gang
of resistors can hope for
is doing what's virtuous
even if it doesn't work out.
And this relates to
another part of stoicism
namely that it's not only
about learning how to live,
it's about learning how to die as well.
Seneca here, plagiarized
by Montaigne said,
"He who has learned to die
has unlearned how to serve."
And his Epic Titus said,
"Keep death before your eyes every day
and then you will never
have any object thought
or any excessive desire."
All of this according to Haddo,
it means that we should remain present
as if every moment is paradoxically
our first and our last.
Okay.
So does part two of season
four of "Attack On Titan",
give us a masterclass
on how to become Stoics?
Not really,
but much of the season
shows us what can happen
when hatred, anger and fear take priority
over logical deliberation
in the pursuit of virtue.
This helps us understand
what the stoic saw
as an undesirable and
unvirtuous way to live.
And towards the end of the season,
we start to see how moving
beyond negative passions
and emotions to approach things
from a more logical perspective,
leads a group of characters
to overcome their hatred
for the sake of the common good.
And this gets at coolest
thing about stoicism.
It's really a philosophy of life.
The stoics weren't
primarily focused on (beep)
like making metaphysical arguments
about the nature of being
or logically deliberating
on the nature of truth,
they think philosophically for the sake
of living a good life,
something that puts them in touch
with the spirit of Socrates.
It also makes them predecessors
of the 19th and 20th century
existential philosophers,
from who philosophy is primarily about
how we live life and make
sense of our existence
and not merely about
how we understand things
in a detached sense.
And if you're interested in learning more
about this tradition,
I can't recommend Pierre Hadot's
"Philosophy As a Way
of Life" highly enough.
So access your library card
Titan and check it out.
But what do you guys think?
Can Attack On Titan
teach us about the virtues of the Stoics
or are we just watching genocide
maniacs have a field day?
Let us know what you
think in the comments.
And definitely let me know
if there are other shows, movies, or games
that you think warrant some
philosophical attention.
Thanks is always to our amazing patrons
for all your support.
And if you haven't checked out
our Patreon page in a while
we have a lot of great
new content going up,
so give it a peek, hit
that subscribe button
like you stoically
blowing up your own boat,
and don't forget to ring that bell.
As always, thanks for watching.
Later.
(upbeat music)
Okay.
We'll stop that one right there,
but you know, not really good advice
for like how to be good brother, I think
but I'm just waiting for
the prompter to get here
so they're gonna put this in the video.